Not everything is a sales pitch, though.
Something you can do absolutely for free is join
the discussion at The David Pakman Show. Subrata
David Pakman dot com slash redit. Something like,
I don't know, it's got to be close to 30000
of our viewers and listeners. Now subscribe to
the sub Reddit. A few interesting posts I spotted
this morning that I want to point out to you, our
friend, the Egg Man showed up. He is on the sub
Reddit and he says, My dream ticket and nightmare
ticket in 2024. Al Franken, Anthony Weiner is the
progressive dream team. Sexual allegations aside.
Mike Pence, Mike Pelo. Twenty twenty four
is the nightmare that ruins sleep. The man,
of course, signing off with his typical Shulem.
Yeah, I, I'm not so sure about Franken. Weiner,
Franken Weiner may be a tough sell. I think
strategically doesn't mean Al Franken is not
a brilliant guy. Doesn't mean Anthony Weiner
is not an excellent debater and all that. I
think that's a tough one. And as far as the
right goes, my money would be if you give
me an even money bet is the 2024 ticket. Mike
Pence and Mike Pillow. Michael Mandel, of course
I say it is not. I'm taking the no bet on that
one. But interesting to hear from the Egemen their
user bread tube forever posted. What's Tulsi
Gabbard up to? You might be asking. It turns out
Tulsi was on Fox News comparing cancer culture
to ISIS and al-Qaida in a Fox News interview.
Yes, I don't think Tulsi is doing anything
that's surprising to anyone that has been paying
attention to Tulsi Gabbard for some time. And then
use your s.m. Ninety seven has a tip for listening
to The David Pakman Show pro-life TYP. Listen to
The David Pakman Show on one point three x speed
concentrated Pakman saying increasing the playback
speed brings a bit more energy to the broadcast.
More info in less time. Sometimes I even go for
one point five to one point six x speed. Give it a
shot and try it out for yourself. And some people
reporting in the comments that they actually
listen to the show on two speed. You know,
I've talked with other podcasters about whether
we find it offensive that people speed us up to
listen to the episodes more quickly. I really
don't. I mean, there for some people,
listening to shows is something you do
sort of like for pleasure. Some people can you
imagine some people find it relaxing. I know
some people fall asleep to the sound of my voice
because it's so to some soporific. But I don't if
you're just trying to get information and you
have a bunch of podcasts you're listening to,
I take no offense to people listening more
quickly. I sometimes do that with certain
types of content. But if you're just listening for
pleasure rather than to cram, like for an exam,
then maybe you listen at one X and I know
sometimes I don't speak that quickly.
And so I take no offense whatsoever. Listen, at
any speed that you want, just be aware that the
show will start sounding like Ben Shapiro's show
at about two X, and that may be triggering to some
people. Join the discussion. Join the sub Reddit.
It's free at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit